bonsoir que le blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous sur erquy soir qu'est
ce qui a motivé selon vous l'écriture de
cette tribune de vladimir poutine et
surtout acquiesce qu'elle s'adresse je
crois que le premier motif c'est
évidemment de resituer la relation entre
les ukrainiens et les russes dans leur
contexte historique dans le temps long
je dis bien entre les ukrainiens et
russes puisque le titre de l'article
c'est le fait que les ukrainiens et les
russes constituent en fait un même
peuple
le deuxième motif c'est comme votre
sujet là la montre et de dénoncer un
projet anti russie ça c'est la thèse du
complot permanent contre la russie et
puis le troisième motif me semble-t-il
c'est que la dernière partie de
l'article l'unss entrevoir des
possibilités de compromis si
naturellement les parties au conflit s'y
prête
et si les pays qu'ils sont les parrains
de l'accord de minsk poussent dans ce
sens
alors à qui est destiné cet article
vient d'abord aux russes bien sûr
certainement et les russes ont dû
apprécier toutes les références
historiques que donne l'admirent poutine
également la description de la grande
russie qui a subi beaucoup de
difficultés et deux revers c'est en
deuxième lieu les ukrainiens et
d'ailleurs il est traduit en ukrainien
pour signifier d'une part les lignes
rouges à ne pas franchir
vis-à-vis de la russie et d'autre part
pour dire que la solution du nom basse
elle est dans l'accord de minsk purement
et simplement
il n'y a qu'à appliquer l'accord de misc
même si les dirigeants ukrainiens en
quelques réticences à aller dans ce sens
et puis les pays tiers évidemment les
pays tiers alors les pays tiers
ce qui est curieux c'est que ce cet
article qui était l'autre et 22 pages
est publié sur le site du kremlin
depuis deux jours qu'ils étaient
traduits par le site du kremlin en
anglais mais qui n'est pas diffusée à la
grande presse internationale et que je
pense que dans les prochains jours ceci
arrivera aujourd'hui nous sommes le 14
juillet et a très peu de journaux en
france mais dans la presse anglo saxonne
on n'a pas vu beaucoup d'écho à ce à
ceux à cet article à cette tribune du
président de la russie
et je pense que ça devrait venir dans
les prochains jours la difficulté c'est
qu'il est très long et que chacun
choisira les extraits qui lui qui lui
conviennent bien entendu que ce soit en
faveur de la russie en faveur de
l'ukraine pour aller vers une solution
pour créer des difficultés je pense
aussi que les historiens aient et lé et
les gens qui s'occupent de stratégie
vont se pencher avec beaucoup d'intérêt
sur ce texte inclut blanchemaison ses
tribunes est ce que c'est une leçon
d'histoire le chef du kremlin utilise le
passé pour expliquer le présent quels
faits historiques relater ici vous ont
le plus marqué oui c'est une leçon
d'histoire événementiel ce n'est pas une
leçon d'histoire au sens des historiens
qui décrivent les grands mouvements
sociaux économiques qui font évoluer la
situation dans le monde mais c'est une
histoire très précises qui remonte au 9e
siècle par conséquent plus d'un
millénaire avec des détails extrêmement
précis date et qui sont destinés aux
spécialistes russes qui connaissent
parfaitement bien leur histoire je crois
que en effet dans cette histoire on peut
relever plusieurs éléments d'abord des
éléments étonnant j'ai relevé en tout
cas en lisant le texte
au moins quatre critiques de l'époque
soviétique
la première est que la responsable
première responsabilité de ce qui est
arrivé ensuite dans la dans la
l'indépendance la prise d'indépendance
de l'ukraine et d'autres états eh bien
c'est la constitution de 1924 c'est à
dire la constitution de lénine qui
prévoit que chaque république fédérative
peut reprendre son indépendance
lorsqu elles le désirent
c'est une bombe à retardement des
poutines dans son texte est en effet la
bombe a explosé en 1991 et puis il dit
aussi que les dirigeants veulent se
fixer le terme qu'il emploie ont
finalement flatter les différences entre
russes ukrainiens et biélorusses alors
qu'il s'agit fondamentalement et
culturellement d'un seul peuple dont il
pointe là aussi une responsabilité
et puis il dit ensuite que son maître
son mentor le premier maire élu de saint
pétersbourg
monsieur sobczak lui avait dit que
lorsque les pays ont pris leur
indépendance lorsque l'union soviétique
a écrêté est bien et il aurait fallu
revenir aux frontières d'avant les
traités de 1922
c'est à dire les traités qui ont seuls
dès la première guerre mondiale
alors évidemment quand on y regarde de
près ça veut dire que on aurait dû
garder en russie à la fédération de
russie
un certain nombre de territoires qui
sont partis ailleurs et puis poutine
critique vertement la décision de
khrouchtchev de rattacher la crimée à
l'ukraine en 1954 et il se dit même que
c'était tout à fait contraire aux règles
de droit international de l'époque alors
c'est difficile de démontrer exactement
si c'était contraire aux droits le roc
de l'international
mais il est vrai que l'ukraine avait une
voix l'onu comme la biélorussie à
l'époque de l'union soviétique c'était
les arrangements de 1945 et que
peut-être que ce rattachement en effet
parcours fait par khrouchtchev a été un
peu hâtif en tout cas générateur de
problèmes dans l'avenir et puis poutine
dans ce set attend cet article très long
mentionne le prix réduit qui a été fait
à l'ukraine pendant très longtemps pour
la fourniture de gaz russe et dit
pendant les trois premières années
d'indépendance de l'ukraine ceci a été
dans le fond à un avantage financier
d'environ 85 milliards de dollars ce qui
est énorme
ensuite il décrit une économie craignent
elles qui c'est d'éviter qui a perdu en
30 ans à peu près la moitié de sa
capacité industrielle et qui en effet ne
fait que se déliter en se mettant dans
le fond à la merci du fonds monétaire
international alors il conclut ce
passage en disant que la russie a
toujours été favorable à une coopération
technique et économique avec le cren et
qu'elle le reste
et qu'elle le reste c'est un point tout
à fait tout à fait ouverts voilà donc
les livres et des jeux divers points qui
vont frapper dans la lecture de ce texte
qui est en effet très intéressant et
qu'il faut étudier
dernière question que l'on mélange
maison suite à cet article à cette
publication
quel avenir selon vous pour les rays les
relations russo ukrainiennes
on peut noter que vladimir poutine dans
ce texte regrette que les dirigeants
ukrainiens réécrivent l'histoire qu'il
attribue la famine des années 30 avec
volonté de génocide de la part de moscou
que il essaie d'effacer la contribution
d'un certain nombre d'ukrainiens à la
deuxième guerre mondiale et dit même je
crois que 2000 ukrainiens sont des héros
l'union soviétique et que tout ça est
effacée aujourd'hui dans l'histoire
ukrainienne
il dit aussi que le gouvernement
ukrainien l'élite ukrainienne tourner le
dos à la russie pour se tourner vers
l'occident et qu'elle rêve finalement
d'une entrée à l'otan évidemment à
laquelle la russie est tout à fait
l'opposé et poutine l'a dit d'ailleurs à
joe biden a
il ya quelques semaines je note aussi
que donc dans ce texte l'admirent
poutine ne critique à aucun moment
directement l'union européenne est dit
simplement qu'en 2013
la russie avait proposé une concertation
comme cela se fait d'habitude avec les
pays pour des flux économiques
importants l'union européenne voulait
conclure un accord de coopération voire
d'association avec l'ukraine la russie
demande à être consultés et l'union
européenne refusent cette consultation
et par conséquent n'a pas tenu compte
des flux économiques existant entre la
russie et l'ukraine
c'est dommage peut-être que cette voie
reste ouverte et en effet et
parallèlement aux accords de miss qui
sont la solution pour le nom basse
peut-être poutine ou voit-il la voie à
une négociation économique ou à des
consultations économique en tout cas sur
l'avenir économique de l'ukraine dans
son ensemble qui intéresse naturellement
l'union européenne mais aussi la russie
et sur la reconstruction
il faudra bien prévoir un jour du
dombass de ces deux provinces qui ont
été largement détruite par la guerre
donc là on voit peut-être des pistes il
faut exploiter et peut-être que vladimir
poutine a tant que l'union européenne
plutôt que de prendre ce texte à la
légère prennent des points
ils sont positifs ou qui peuvent être
interprétées comme positif pour aller de
l'avant
merci que dans une maison pour votre
analyse
par rapport donc à ce texte publié par
parle valdimir poutine je rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales